ce printemps certains marcheurs qui se
sont aventurés sur les plages du
bas-saint-laurent et de la gaspésie ont
été témoins d'un triste spectacle des
centaines de petits animaux marins
échoués sur les rives du fleuve
phénomènes naturels ou intoxication
nous avons tenté de comprendre ce qui
avait bien pu leur arriver
[Musique]
vous
oh
je m'appelle mathieu gosselin j'aime
beaucoup faire de la photo d'oiseaux
c'est parti pour essayer de capturer
quelques bonnes photos et j'ai remarqué
qu'ils avaient une énorme comme une
flaque et rose dans l'amérique est en
train de descendre et jeu ça mais ça m'a
intrigué j'ai vu que c'était des
concombres de mer vraiment beaucoup de
concombre et moi j'habite ici depuis que
je suis tout petit et j'ai jamais vu
autant de concombres de mer sur la plage
en même temps ça arrive des fois un de
temps à autres surtout dans les grandes
marées d'automne
mais au printemps c'était la première
fois alors ça m'a intrigué lorsque j'ai
pris des photos et je vais partager sur
facebook
matthew goss lait n'est pas le seul à
avoir documenté cet échouement survenue
à la fin mars
le phénomène a été observé un temps au
bas-saint-laurent en gaspésie
oui en fait j'ai des amis qui est qu'ils
sont habitués de la plage toulon de
rimouski d'un jusqu'à matane et tout le
monde va confirmer qu'il y en avait et
qui en avait plus que d'habitude même
dans la région de sainte luce et avait
plusieurs espèces visibles encore
vivante dans les flaques
difficile de dire avec précision combien
il y en avait
mais on peut certainement compter par
centaines les soluces écarlate les
concombres et les étoiles de mer échoué
sur la plage
ces animaux marins sont tous cousins ils
appartiennent à l'embranchement des
échinodermes je me suis demandé qu'est
ce qui se passait pas ce qu'est parce
que c'est inhabituel puis
l'environnement m mais te laisse
beaucoup et puis comme c'est ma plage
dans le fond je passe mes journées ici
si une variation dans la cale à la
qualité de l'eau ou quelque chose de
dangereux dans l'environnement qui peut
tuer autant de cocons dommage je voulais
savoir qu'est ce qui explique cet
échouement de toute évidence il ne
s'agit pas d'un agent toxique croit les
scientifiques à qui nous avons parlé car
selon eux on aurait dû trouver une plus
grande variété d'organismes mort comme
des poissons par exemple autre cause
possible
un épisode de fort débit d'eau douce
dans le fleuve provoqué par beaucoup de
pluie et une fonte rapide de la neige
ces événements entraînent une diminution
de la salinité de l'eau et peuvent
causer une mortalité importante chez
certains organismes qui vivent en eaux
peu profondes
mais dans ce cas précis cette hypothèse
n'est pas retenu par les experts
les tentacules déployés catherine
couillard étudie les concombres de mer à
l'institut maurice-lamontagne la
chercheuse en écophysiologie a expliqué
en entrevue à la radio d'ici gaspésie
les îles la cause probable de cet
échouement des kilos d'herbe est
d'arriver à trouver et qu'il ya eu un
épisode de fort vent de nord du rp
tavelure 20 qui bien que larges qui
pousse vers la plage c'est très très
longtemps plus que 24 à plus de 40 km
heure et puis on peut y avait pas
beaucoup de glace le long des rives le
vin le fort vain pendant une longue
période dans cette direction lorsque tu
as été conforme une grosse vague puis
cette veine le puits sera jusqu'au bord
des côtes qui que tu avais tu crois
pussycat décroche et appel aux
organismes d'aidé accrochés aux enfants
pilotaient se retrouve dans la colonne
d'eau week-end comme des ballons qui
flottent pitre ont fait pousser sur la
plage la scientifique n'est pas inquiète
pour la pêche au concombre de mer une
activité très lucrative pour les
pêcheurs de la région qui les exportent
en asie je pense qu'un événement
ponctuel comme ça de tête en parlait
beaucoup d'impact elle y voit même un
bon côté malgré tout ça nous donne
l'occasion de voir harry chef que
d'enfants des mapic il faut préserver
car on est impliqué après stern dans la
chambre d'à bord de bateaux puis de te
pêcher avec le chat lubie de voir toute
vérité c'est à bandar et les gens qui se
promènent au bar des cages la vois pas
mes cahiers développeurs comme ça et ils
en achètent alors c'est l'occasion de
découvrir toute cette richesse
[Musique]
après avoir vu un échouement important
d'ours l an dernier à rimouski
l'événement de cette année fait
réfléchir mathieu gosselin quand j'étais
tout petit ici là la banquise aller
vraiment loin sur le fleuve
même à ce temps ci de l'année on peut
pas marcher sur la plage et le je pense
que le fait que les glaces protègent
moins des grandes marées le printemps je
pense que ça l'est un impact parce que
de printemps suite avec des échouages
d'animaux qui sont paul en six grands
noms que ceux sur la page aux prêteurs
se préoccupant même si c'est une cause
d'un soleil entre nous dans un cycle où
des événements comme ceux-là vont se
produire plus fréquemment mais ils
peuvent qu'avec les changements
climatiques et paris attend qu'une
intrigue de plus en plus de phénomènes
extrêmes
alors comme ça de moins en moins glas de
l'ondé rire puis tout seul cette partie
du spectre de variations climatiques est
accrue des consuls et à nous pour voir
plus tard est de plus en plus souvent
vous êtes attentes et je ne fait pas
reculer pression là que subissent les
organismes avec les barrières comme
crime hall la suite
ben j'ai l'impression que mon garçon qui
est ici aujourd'hui va pouvoir apprendre
des noms d'animaux que j'ai pas pu
reprendre quand j'étais là quand j'avais
son âge parce que l on les voyait pas
pour le reste ça va on va être obligé de
s'adapter vite faire avec les
changements n'a pas trop le choix
oui